alors la transplantation d'îlots
pancréatiques
elle est préconisée pour plutôt les
diabétiques de type 1 et pourquoi une
certaine catégorie de patients
donc ce sera les patients chez qui la
suit nos thérapies ne fonctionne pas ou
ne fonctionnent plus et du coup la
glycémie il va être en totale
dérégulation tout le temps et donc du
coup on va avoir des phases
d'hyperglycémie des phases
d'hypoglycémie et qui peuvent mener à
des coma hypoglycémique donc à très
court terme et qui engage très
rapidement le pronostic vital de ses
passions donc du coup le but ce serait
de remplacer les cellules bêta
défectueuse du patient parle des îlots
pancréatiques donc d'un donneur non
diabétiques et pour cela on récupère le
pancréas downloader on va isoler les
îlots de spank là et on va les
transplanter dans le foie et ses îlots
ça va être les des meilleurs gagnent
qu'on retrouve donc dans pointe claire
et qui sont responsables de la
régulation de la glycémie et donc du
taux de sucre dans le sang et ses îlots
donc quelles sont ces îlots sont
composées de différentes cellules
donc on a les cellules bêta qui sont les
cellules qui sécrètent de l'insuline
l'hormone hypoglycémiante on a également
laissé une alfa qui elle sécrète le but
gag - qui est une hormone hyperglycémie
rond qui permettent de réguler la
glycémie dans la circulation sanguine de
regret donc à l'heure actuelle les îlots
sont transportés dans fois mais on est
aussi en train de chercher de nouveaux
sites d'implantation qu'il pourrait plus
bénéfique que le poids ou laboratoires
on va développer différents types de
projets axés sur des nouveaux
traitements
on a un axe de recherche qui va être
comment administrer l'insuline exogènes
c'est à dire remplacer les injections
soit par
une mini station moral de l'insuline
soit par un dispositif qui permet qui
serait transplantables mais qui
permettrait un film de réagir et de
l'autre partie on développe
l'optimisation la thérapie cellulaire
pour les diabétiques donc soit
l'amélioration de la transnationale aux
pratiques ou alors par le développement
d'un bon gré à bertry ciel qui se fait
via une start up qu'on a créé ce
pancréas artificiel en fait c'est une
poche qui contient des cellules qui vont
être transplantées chez un patient et ça
va permettre de ne plus avoir de
traitement immuno suppresseurs donc on
pourrait éventuellement proposer cette
thérapie a énormément voire même les
enfants
donc pour ce faire cette société des
films elle développe et pousse vers les
essais cliniques
ce dispositif est son nom dans la phase
de marquage ce et c'est à dire qu'il
faut que le dispositif sont reconnus
fiable par an par les autorités dont
clients sont là que d'un tank du côté
réglemente donc le pancréas artificiel
allie deux idées qui va être le côté
artificiel qui va être pas par cette
poche qui va contenir les cellules donc
le côté vivant et le côté bio du coup
bioartificiels donc on va transplanter
des cellules dans cette poche et l'ont
finalement de l'autre ne va pas se
rendre compte qu'il est transplanté donc
n'ont pas besoin de frapper en lieu de
création
aujourd'hui la suite elle se prend sous
forme d'injection et on essaye de
développer une mode d'administration par
bourahli rule qui contiendrait
d'insuline
on a montré que c'était
fonctionnelle chez le petit animal on a
montré que notre procédé et est
industrialisable on a été fabriqué dans
une industrie on a vu que ça c'était 5
fonctionnait et maintenant il faut qu'on
arrive à pousser ce projet encore une
fois vers l'essai clinique pour valider
cette insuline qui pourrait se prendre
sous forme de cachets parce qu'on est
vraiment sur un modèle insuline lente
parce que voilà la gélule qu'il faut
qu'elle passe toute la digestion avant
de les délivrer son insuline
donc on serait sur un remplacement une
insuline basale donc une des injections
chez ces patients diabétiques de type 1
ou l'injection chez les patients
diabétiques de type 2 qui va auquel ils
doivent à laquelle il doit se plier les
patients diabétiques sont obligés de se
piquer plusieurs fois par jour est
vraiment l'idée c'est de haut -
remplacer une injection
donc on change pas les injections avec
les bonus etc
par contre il ya une des injections
qu'on pourrait éventuellement remplacer
par une prise orale et on a aussi les
passionnés optique de type 2 donc sept
personnes plutôt âgées qui vont avoir un
peu à une appréhension quand on leur dit
de faire leur diabète y prit un très bon
moral et à un moment donné leur plein le
parc leur pancréas et et cuisez faut
qu'ils passent aux injections et ces
personnes-là stress a pour à cette
injection c'est que c'est comme ça
qu'ils étaient encore plus malade alors
que sa solution est donc si on pouvait
remplacer cette injection par justement
un autre médicament le traitement serait
mieux suivis et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
essayait de se développer et
l'administration
donc on travaille au centre européen
d'étude du diabète qui est un centre de
recherche basé à strasbourg et nos
projets de recherche sont menées
notamment en interne mais également sur
sur des collaborations à l'étranger à la
fois pour nous permettre d'avoir des
idées de ne pas faire la même chose que
d'autres équipes et d'avoir aussi
d'autres domaines de recherche qui nous
enrichir faire nous faire aller plus
loin dans vos recherches
donc dans une équipe de recherche
translationnelle donc on est vraiment
sur de la techno appliquée donc dans le
concret et donc c'est ça aussi qui nous
plaît et qui nous pousse à avancer mieux
et plus ce qui nous apporte du confort
en fait c'est aussi ce genre de
manifestation on sort du labo on
rencontre les passagers malades et ce
qui nous ramène à la réalité on sort un
peu du nez de notre baiia se montent à
bord at war et ça nous ramène à la
réalité donc ça aussi c'est c'est une
part importante de la structure à
strasbourg